hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
starting in chapter one and then
continuing on and deepening in
chapter two miguel de una muno in tragic
sense of life
is going to talk about the meaning
the significance of knowledge
and how it springs from desire
and serves and in a certain respect is
also characteristic
of human life and in chapter two
he invokes two very common starting
places for discussion about knowledge
aristotle and metaphysics book one and
the genesis account
of the garden of eden in metaphysics
book
one aristotle tells us that all human
beings
by their nature by being the kind of
beings that they are
desire to to know he doesn't tell us
exactly what they desire to know as a
matter of fact
this varies considerably from person to
person
community to community and epoch to
epoch
there are some things now that that are
knowable for us that weren't knowable
for them
but as a general statement everybody
wants to know
something and very often after they've
known one thing they want to know
other things as well in the genesis
account we have
the famous you know tree that you're not
supposed to eat from
the knowledge of good and evil is what
it's supposed to provide and god says
hey you can have any tree
any fruit you like just not that one and
human beings through whatever story that
you're going to use
wind up becoming you know sentient in a
new way
having knowledge and they're punished as
a result of that
and there are other accounts of
knowledge but these are
in certain respect very evocative uh
ways
of of looking at things it is really
clear that all human beings
do desire some knowledge the question
then
is why is there just one single reason
why we desire knowledge does does this
knowing something about knowledge
help us to figure this out and you know
one approach to this would be saying
well we
want knowledge because it's
intrinsically
valuable knowing the intellectual
faculties are the highest part of the
human being it's what distinguishes us
from the other
animals so why wouldn't we want to
realize the highest
part of ourself and a lot of
philosophers and indeed many other
people in culture have taken
such a position and um
una muno is a little bit suspicious of
this rightly so he says
knowledge for the sake of knowledge is
say what you will
nothing but a dismal begging of the
question
and we should say a little bit about
that when we talk about something
begging the question and we're you know
using the term rightly we don't mean
raising new questions or
uh not answering other questions we mean
that if there's a circular
argument there knowledge for the sake of
knowledge why
for the sake of knowledge why for the
sake of knowledge there's a circularity
it doesn't really explain anything and
we can come up with all sorts of other
things
well we have a epistemological desire
right episteme is knowledge calling it
an epistemological desire
not really settling anything why do we
desire to know and the answer is
actually going to be
multi-sided for unamuno he actually
talks
about a love of knowledge which is you
might say
based in our body and we share
to some degree with the other animals he
says
we must distinguish between the desire
or appetite
for knowing apparently and at first
sight for the love of knowledge itself
between the eagerness of the to taste
the fruit of the tree of knowledge
and the necessity of knowing for the
sake of living
the latter which gives us direct and
immediate knowledge and which in a
certain sense might be called
unconscious knowledge is common to both
men and animals well that which
distinguishes us from them is reflective
knowledge
than knowing that we know and i think in
a certain sense he's actually like
mixing things up a little bit here
because we can talk about this
unconscious knowledge as being like
again what we share in common
with animals that smell something new on
the air and they want it what is that
i haven't smelled that before let me go
and check this out
or they encounter a new object or they
encounter
one of their own kind after they have
matured enough to where the sexual
instincts and desires are now operative
within them
there are so many other things curiosity
in the sense of what we might call a
basic animal curiosity
is evident in so many animals
and definitely in human infants i mean
that's part of why
if you have ever had kids you know that
from age about you know
one and a half to four one of your main
jobs is to keep them from
damaging or killing themselves because
they follow their curiosity
in all sorts of ways that could be
deleterious to them putting anything
whatsoever in their mouth opening
cupboards you know pulling things down
all that sort of stuff we might even say
that the instinct of cats
to push things off of places maybe
that's founded in a kind of knowledge
i wonder what happens if i do this if i
push this button
right and so there there is something
like that that we could call a
knowledge not for the sake of anything
else but just to know
but what else is determinative about
human beings
is that some of us think of ourselves as
interested in knowledge for its own sake
and as unum points out
unless again aristotle points this out
as well at a certain point
once we have satisfied the demands
and desires of self-preservation
the needs of life itself
answering those necessities of knowing
he says in order to live
we have other knowledge which we he says
we can call super superfluous knowledge
or knowledge deluxe right as a luxury
which may in its turn come to constitute
and this is very interesting
a new necessity it becomes something we
desire
and we desire sometimes even more
strongly than the
then the knowledge that will help keep
us alive
says curiosity only awakes and becomes
operative
after the necessity of knowing for the
sake of living
is satisfied and although sometimes in
the conditions under which the human
race is actually living it may not so
befall
curiosity may prevail over necessity and
knowledge over hunger
nevertheless the primordial fact is
curiosity
spraying from the necessity of knowing
in order to live so curiosity
is something that is in addition to
living but it's also springing out of
this this desire
to live as well so
we seek out as he says truth
and he talks about is very interesting
when men believe themselves to be
seeking truth for its own sake they're
in fact seeking something different
what are they seeking life in truth
they're seeking out a way of being
that connects them with what they
conceive of as
truth truth comes to take on its own
value
for them and it comes to be something
that which we can
share with each other this doesn't
really answer
fully the question of what's the reason
why we want to know
what's the why and una muno in chapter
1 will tell us that it is
for for two main reasons
it says all knowledge has an ultimate
object
we learn something either for an
immediate practical end or in order to
complete
the rest of our knowledge even the
knowledge that appears the most
theoretical
of least immediate application to the
non-intellectual necessities of life
answers to a necessity which is real
to a reason of economy and thinking to a
principle of unity and continuity of
consciousness
so part of our drive to know things
is to actually connect them together to
assimilate
to way out the contradictions or
conflicts
between them and decide on one side or
another or to do justice to both sides
to
harmonize to integrate the things that
we know
but we also are in fact driven
by the need to he says persist
in our being he brings up spinoza
here and but he could bring up so many
others as well
saying that what we attempt to do
is to remain in existence knowledge is
primarily at the service
of the instinct of self-preservation
which is indeed
as we've said with spinoza its very
essence
and so it can be said that it is the
instinct of self-preservation
that makes perceptible for us the
reality and truth of the world he says
so a good part of our knowledge is
really coming out of
how do we keep ourselves alive how do we
have a life and he's got this really
interesting way of framing it that i
very much like here he says in effect
that which has existence for us is
precisely that which in one way or
another
we need to know in order to exist
ourselves
objective existence as we know it is a
dependence of our own
personal existence and if we're thinking
about things at a perceptual level
this is clearly true you know our
bodies are adapted to doing certain
things not necessarily to living in
modern industrial society
where we wind up with some problems
because of
you know dealing with things that our
bodies are not adapted to
but it's the things that our bodies are
adapted to
um because of where we were you know
generations and generations ago
that give us our distinctive ways of
knowing the world that are quite
different than that of a mosquito
or of if a plant can be said to know the
world of various plants
or even of animals closer to us like
elephants and cats
and pigs or ravens
you know other corvids crows things like
that
so that's a an important thing he also
talks about
in the course of getting to know the
world
we have through generation after
generation after generation
developed as he calls it stored you know
a stored up knowledge
or a fund of knowledge which then we can
rely upon but every generation has to
re-learn
over and over again as well
he tells us uh here we go beings which
appear to be endowed
with perception perceive in order to be
able to live and only perceive insofar
as they require to
but this stored up knowledge the utility
in which it had its origin
being exhausted has come to constitute a
fund of knowledge
far exceeding that required for the bare
necessities of living and that is what
we spend
most of our time with this book is a
product
of that fund is it not and so he talks
about the
the sciences um you know once we begin
developing these he says
the primordial fact is curiosity sprang
from the necessity of knowledge in order
to live
this is the dead weight and gross matter
carried in the matrix
of science all these things that we
learned but then we can also want to
seek knowledge
within the sciences in order to serve
human
needs and desires medicine is a prime
example of that
you know medicine is not an exact
science as they remind you if you go in
for
surgery you have to sign a little waiver
that tells you
that anything could happen but there's a
good probability that they know what
they're doing
and it's at the it's at the service of
some human needs and desires
our massive improvements in
communications
and technology these are for human
beings and they are driven by
science by something that we have a
capacity for so we have all sorts of
ways
in which we know and we have all sorts
of
reasons for desiring to know but they're
always going to come back
in some way to a basis of wanting to
perpetuate and persist in
being in that is to live
and to live better to continue
to flourish as we could say and so
knowledge
it may appear to be something that
people pursue for their own sake but
that is
sort of an outgrowth of it and really we
have to keep thinking about how
knowledge fits into our vital needs or
we'll lose
track of the whole point of why
we seek knowledge and why these accounts
or stories can still be so
important for us today in understanding
the nature of human beings
as knowing creatures
you